wir brauchen den Ackergaul der
Stromversorgung heute morgen gab es
weder Wind noch Sonne jede Stunde die
wir Atomkraft weiter nutzen entsteht ja
weitere Atome und ein Endlager ist immer
noch nicht in sich wir sollten mehr
Angst vor dem Klimawandel haben als vor
der Atomkraft zwischen 20 und bis zu 40
Prozent der jährlichen uranimporte in
Deutschland und in der EU kommen aus
Russland und wir haben Wassermangel
ELN ja ich bin doch nicht für Kohle ich
bin für ein neu
[Musik]
ich bin für Kern Energie weil ich glaube
dass wir ohne sie den Klimawandel nicht
in den Griff bekommen
[Musik]
ich bin genervt von so Positionen die
eine sehr schwierige Technologie als
sehr einfach verkauft
[Musik]
mitten in der größten Energiekrise ist
der zurück der Streit um die Atomkraft
bei mir beim Psychologen auf der Couch
[Musik]
ihr beiden herzlich willkommen Ulrike
Linus schön dass Ihr da seid hi hallo
Linus allererste Eindruck ihr kennt euch
nicht ihr trefft euch hier bei mir auf
der Couch zum ersten mal was sagst du
zuhörige ja noch kann ich ja noch nicht
so viel sagen ich würde sagen wir haben
sicher unsere Differenzen aber ich bin
gespannt wie sich unsere Diskussion
entwickeln wird und ähm überhaupt dass
wir erstmal freundlich uns anlächeln
können auch trotz unserer Differenzen
finde ich ganz gut Ulrike dein erster
Eindruck von Linus ja sehr sympathisch
und sicher sehr diskussionsfreudig und
ähm haben wir endlich unsere Differenzen
haben und vielleicht auch unsere Dinge
über die wir uns einigen können und ja
freue mich auf ein interessanten
Austausch Energie ist ja immer auch
Ökologie und ganz zentral auch
Klimaschutz welchen Stellenwert hat
Natur Ökologie bei euch im Leben ich
würde sagen mir ist Ökologie auf jeden
Fall wichtig ich würde es nicht mit
Naturschutz zwingend gleichsetzen weil
eigentlich finde ich Nachhaltigkeit
wichtig weil mir Menschen wichtig ich
bin klimaaktivist weil ich will dass es
Menschen gut geht und dass wir auch in
Zukunft gut leben können bei dir du
lebst auf dem Land mitten in der Natur
ist es da anders oder sagst du auch nee
Menschen zuerst Natur dann irgendwann
ich glaube das geht nur gemeinsam also
Mensch und Natur ich glaube und gerade
im Moment sehen wir dass wenn es der
Natur schlecht geht geht es uns Menschen
auch gewaltig schlecht das ist eine
letzte Sommer war wirklich erschreckend
geradezu es ist Krieg in Europa wir
haben einen klimanotfall auf der ganzen
Welt und wir haben eine Klimakrise die
wir gerade massiv spüren und in dieser
Zeit wird wieder diskutiert wird
gestritten in Deutschland ist Atomkraft
die Antwort auf diese Problematik wenn
du das Wort Atomkraftwerke hörst muss
man ganz konkret zu machen was kommt
jetzt als erstes in den Kopf in
effizient veraltet hat nichts mehr mit
meiner Realität zu tun Zukunft CO2-freie
Strom zuverlässig günstige
Energieversorgung für die ganze Welt
Ulrike du bist in einem Verein der heißt
mothers von nuklear wer sind die
strahlenden Mütter
wir sind nicht wir sind ein sehr kleiner
Verein ja weil in Deutschland ja doch
die Sorge sagen wir mal ähm immer groß
ist also wir sind aber sehr positiv der
Kernkraft gegenüber und meinen das ist
die Zukunft auf unsere Kinder wärst du
stolz auf eine mother von nuklear ich
wäre nicht stolz weil ich den nicht
zustimmen würde also ich glaube es ist
endlich ein gutes Recht das zu machen
aber ich glaube vorne und hinten sind da
Sachen die für mich einfach unstimmig
sind also zum Beispiel eben dass wir
Uran ja genau wie Gas auch zu ganz
großen Anteilen aus Russland beziehen
oder zumindest vor dem Ukraine Krieg aus
Russland bezogen haben also zwischen 20
und bis zu 40% der jährlichen
uranimporte in Deutschland und in der EU
kommen aus Russland das will ich auch
nicht unterstützen ich glaube was
natürlich auch klar ist ist dass wir in
der Alternative haben zu nuklearen
Energie die sauberer und einfach
umzusetzen ist und das sind eben
erneuerbare Energien dass es eben Solar
das ist die Windkraft und die
Technologien die wir nutzen können um
Energie zu speichern also zum Beispiel
eben auch Wasserstoff das Problem der
Energiewende ist einfach das wir eine
zuverlässige wir brauchen den Ackergaul
der Strom sorgen heute morgen gab es
weder Wind noch Sonne das heißt ich habe
bei der elektricity Map geguckt es war
der braune Balken wie Kohle war ganz
dick aber da müssen wir aber eine
Geschichtsstunde machen wieso das
passiert ist und aus meiner Sicht ist
das eben passiert weil wir verschlafen
haben die erneuerbaren Energien
auszubauen nach der Wirtschaftskrise
sind ganz viele Unternehmen die super
gutes Solaranlagen in Deutschland gebaut
haben sind kollabiert bei ihnen nicht
geholfen wurde und jetzt geht's nicht um
streckbetrieb es geht nicht um diesen
einen Winter den wir jetzt irgendwie
überbrücken wollen sondern mir geht es
um die große Frage Atomkraft in
Deutschland braucht es eine Zukunft oder
nicht und wir steigen jetzt voll rein in
diesen Streit und brauchen Platz helft
ihm ein bisschen Platz zu machen wir
wollen alle das Klima retten aber wie
das geht darüber kann man sich tierisch
streiten und jetzt deine Meinung ganz
intuitiv ohne dass du alle Fakten kennen
musst bist du für Atomkraft oder gegen
bitte jetzt in die Kommentare
[Musik]
ihr beiden so viel streiten Deutschland
um Atomkraft es gibt Demonstrationen wo
es früher immer nur hieß atomkraft nein
danke jetzt gibt es wieder zwei Lager
und genau die will ich jetzt einmal mit
euch greifbar machen zwei Schilder für
eine Demonstration und ihr schreibt
jetzt mal bitte eure Kernaussage was wir
bei einer Demo hochhalten würdet in das
Schild
so nehmen wir eure beiden Schilder
vielleicht nebeneinander einmal gucken
was wir haben
AKW nee
erneuerbare ja und bei dir lieber Krise
Fragezeichen Kernkraft erster Eindruck
von den beiden auf der Couch maximal
distanziert aber auch ziemlich kühl und
das ist psychologisch spannend wenn man
streitet weil Konflikte ganz oft zu kalt
ablaufen da hat man Angst davor dass man
sich anschreibt oder ausrastet das
wollen wir nicht also Hitze wollen wir
vermeiden und dann bleibt man so passiv
aggressiv sagt nicht was wirklich Sache
es ist wenn Dinge unter den Teppich
gekehrt ich mache jetzt was mit den
beiden wo es genau ums Gegenteil geht es
soll heiß werden und ich weiß noch
überhaupt nicht ob das funktioniert aber
wenn es funktioniert ist das hier für
den Streit Gold wert
und ich weiß es wird euch Überwindung
kosten es hat mich bei der Probe hier
auch sehr viel Überwindung gekostet aber
ich möchte mit euch zusammen ja warte ab
mit euch zusammen schreien so laut ihr
könnt okay ich habe dafür sogar noch
hier ein Gadget ein Dezibel Messgerät um
dann gleich zu gucken weil wir es ein
bisschen wie eine Challenge machen
wollen wie laut ihr so kommt wenn ich
jetzt so rede sind wir so bei 50 mal
gucken ob einer von euch das richtig
hoch sollte
die schreien oder ich darf einfach
nein danke ich dachte wir müssen uns
jetzt eine halbe Stunde Aufwärmen hier
waren alle waren so alle waren peinlich
berührt beim Schreiben ihr seid direkt
am Start gegeneinander eure Statements
Kernkraft ist vielleicht das eine nein
danke vielleicht das andere vielleicht
fällt Euch noch mehr ein brüllt euch an
wir brauchen so
sich nicht zwischen zwei Übeln
entscheiden Atomkraft ist keine
Zukunftstechnologie wir haben kein
Atomkraftwerke mehr und wir können keine
neuen Atomkraftwerke bauen natürlich
können
Atomkraft so jetzt in großen Stil gebaut
werden würde würde sie sofort billiger
werden in den nächsten 10 Jahren radikal
weniger machen erst ab 10 Jahren würden
wir die Effekte von Atomkraft langsam
die Effekte der drei Atomkraftwerke die
letztes Jahr abgeschaltet wird haben
eine klare Alternative zu
Atomkraftwerken und das sind eine neue
wahre Energie die ausbaubar sind die
speicherbar sind und die uns Grünen
wirklich grünen Strom der meine
Generation nicht belastet herstellen
können das Problem ist die
Speicherbarkeit das sagst du wir haben
nämlich noch gar keine Speicher wie
lange wollt Ihr denn warten bisher die
Speicher aber Atomkraftwerke sind ja
auch nicht da im Sommer diesen Sommer
wurde in Frankreich mehr als die Hälfte
der Atomkraftwerke wegen Sicherheit
kein Grund in Deutschland sie
funktionieren die Kernkraftwerke ganz
anders die haben eine externe Kühlung
wir brauchen dafür nicht das Wasser und
Deutschland hat bei der
sicherheitsbetrachtung der
Kernkraftwerke endlos 2 erst in diesem
Herbst war klar dass wir
Atomkraftwerke nachrüsten müssen weil
sie nicht gut genug ausgestattet sind
und weil es ähnlich aber was ist das für
eine Logik das wir in Deutschland unsere
Kernkraftwerke abstellen und
gleichzeitig beschweren dass die
Franzosen ihre kampfkraftwerke nicht am
Start haben kann Frankreich auch die
deutsche Atomkraftwerke sind nicht
sicher und um sie sicher zu halten ist
das stimmt unglaublich teuer und auch
wieso ist es denn eigentlich okay das in
einer Zeit der Klimakrise von der
gesamten EU 2,4 Milliarden Kubikmeter
Wasser für Atomkraft verwendet werden
und wir haben Wassermangel entfernt
genau das gleiche Mutter
dass den Menschen gut geht wir brauchen
Strom ich weiß torgenuss wie ging es
euch ganz kurz erster Eindruck
tat gut tat gut ja ich schreie
eigentlich nicht so gerne aber es ist
eigentlich ganz interessant gewesen weil
wir dann doch unsere Position sehr
prägnant wir waren immer noch sachlich
aber nur noch sehr prägnant
zusammenfassen mussten es hat für mich
Sinn ergeben was mir da
entgegengeschrieben wurde weil es
natürlich das narrativ von Fridays for
future ist es gibt keine Kernkraft mehr
gar nicht die beiden also ich glaube wir
brauchen keine Challenge mehr weil das
war für mich Maximalwert ihr seid so
weit hier im Pegel ausgeschlagen
trotzdem erstmal kurz durchatmen oder
nicht
was ist Dir jetzt in diesem Gespräch
gerade klar geworden ich glaube im Kern
kann man sagen
wir haben einen sehr spezifischen Punkt
wo wir uns nicht zustimmen weil wir
wollen langfristig dasselbe wir wissen
oder wir wissen beide wie aber wir haben
ganz andere Meinung dazu nichts das ist
das ist das Problem ja jetzt im
September wurden wir von der Fridays for
future Demo geschmissen weil wir für
Atomkraft fahren und als wir da uns
gegenseitig die haben dann wir haben
geschrieben Kohle nein Danke und die
Atomkraft nein danke es ging das
traurige war das ist überhaupt nicht um
den CO2-Ausstoß mehr ging also im Kern
ist es halt so dass man auf einer Demo
wenn man die Klima Bewegung ist dann
geht man halt mit dem Konsens dahin weil
diese Bewegung die dazu aufruft die hat
Forderungen in den Forderung steht nicht
Atomkraft und deswegen gibt's dann das
Hausrecht zu sagen das ist nicht gewollt
wir wollen euch hier nicht haben bevor
wir juristisch werden der Punkt ist noch
mal klar beide wollen die
Klimakatastrophe abwenden und die einen
sagen mit Kernkraft und die anderen
sagen auf keinen Fall mit Kern kann was
ich wirklich beachtlich finde sind
mittlerweile neue 78 Prozent der
Deutschen 78 sind laut aktuelle Umfrage
für eine Laufzeitverlängerung unserer
letzten drei Atomkraftwerke das macht
vielleicht in dieser Situation gerade
absolut Sinn weiter geht es dann aber
mit 67 Prozent die sagen noch mal fünf
Jahre weiterlaufen lassen und 41% die
sagen bitte ganz neue Atomkraftwerke
bauen wenn wir diese Zahlen hören nehmt
ihr beide da auch einen Wandel in
Deutschland war das früher überall
atomkraft nein danke Sticker waren und
heute ist das anders ja auf jeden Fall
also ich glaube das ist aber immer
wieder in Krisen so dass Menschen
spontan auch dadurch dass ich die
Medienlandschaft komplett total ändert
und wenn einfach alle konservativen
Zeitungen in Deutschland über drei
Monate
AKWs gezielt bewerben dann ist es nur
logisch dass ein großer Teil der
Bevölkerung ihre Meinung kurzfristig
ändert ich glaube aber nicht dass das
ein langfristiger Effekt sein wird also
in den letzten 10 bis 15 Jahren sind wir
zweimal aus der Atomkraft ausgestiegen
sind zu zweieinhalb mal wieder
eingestiegen das ist alles Zeit die wir
brauchen um die Klimakrise zu bekämpfen
ihr seid gerade wieder so distanziert
ich hatte fast das Gefühl dass wir uns
beim Schreiben schon näher waren in
einem Interview sagst du Ulrike das in
Deutschland ganz viele Menschen die fuse
Ängste vor Atomkraft haben lasst uns da
jetzt tiefer rein und die diffusen
Ängste zu Atomkraft mal ganz konkret
Mann helft mir mal umzubauen bitte
[Musik]
erstmal aber zum Verständnis die Leiter
dient dazu um eure Angst sichtbar zu
machen je mehr Angst du hast desto
weiter kletterst du auf der Leiter hoch
kurzer Test wie viel Angst hast du vor
Markus Söder ja
beide hoch auch die CSU Frau
kennst du den persönlich
besser das macht nicht besser okay dann
einmal wieder runter soweit verstanden
das erste Bild es ist der 26 April 1986
und es kommt im Atomkraftwerk in
Tschernobyl zu einer der größten
reaktorkatastrophen in der Geschichte
zwei Explosionen unfassbar viel
radioaktives Material wird in die
Atmosphäre geschleudert es gibt
Untersuchung wo die Zahlen sehr
schwanken zwischen fünfstelligen zahlen
und 1,4 Millionen Toten wie viel Angst
hast du davon dass noch mal sowas wie
ein Tschernobyl passiert
Linus bevor du kippels hältst du dich an
[Gelächter]
ich komme sonst immerhin
Max noch nicht ich kann auch hier oben
drauf
weil ich weiß dass es also ich habe auch
Angst davor dass es weitere super Gas
gibt ich weiß aber auch dass da wo ich
lebe die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines Super
gauß-verhältnismäßig gering ist also ich
würde sagen ich habe Angst aber ich habe
jetzt z.B jetzt nicht starke starke
Angst davor von ganz unten die helfen in
der Hand was hast Du kaum Angst jetzt
man weiß ja viele Zahlen hat man ja
gehört über was alles passiert ist sind
eben eigentlich nicht so viele Menschen
an Krebs gestorben wie immer hoch
potenziert wird
sehr viele Leute gestorben sind sehr
viele Leute gestorben aber genau aber
ich glaube es ist wahr es war einfach
furchtbar und es waren viele Gründe die
dazu geführt haben die wirklich nie hier
stattfinden würden
geht's ja beim Braunkohleabbau sterben
auch Leute durch die Abbaumaßnahmen und
auch durch die Luftverschmutzung wie
viel Angst habt ihr davor jetzt müssen
wir uns echt anständig
ja
ganz nach oben
Stativ jetzt hier unten frage ich
trotzdem erstmal dich da oben ganz
maximale Angst mehr als viel mehr als
Jungle ja warum weil das einfach so ist
und weil alle Wissenschaftler das Sagen
und weil man es sieht ich meine ich muss
bei uns nur aus dem Fenster gucken die
Bäume sterben und sterben und sterben
wir haben man kann jetzt bei uns schon
die Stromkabel sehen die zu dem
großkotzenburger Kohlekraftwerk gehen
das konnten wir früher nicht jetzt ist
der Wald ist durchsichtig geworden die
Buchen sterben und das macht mir echt
Angst so bei dir maximal weit oben viel
weiter noch als eben bei wenn auch bei
dir nicht ganz so großen Unterschied ja
weil
faktisch dass die größte Krise ist die
wir in unserer die wir in unserem Leben
erfahren werden das ist die größte Krise
unseres Lebens und auch darüber hinaus
und ich glaube deswegen ist es auch
absolut berechtigte vor Angst zu haben
der Punkt ist dass ist eine Sache gibt
vielleicht gar keine Angst oder bei der
ich auf dem Boden stehen würde und das
dann halt erneuerbare weil ich will mich
nicht zwischen zwei Monstern entscheiden
müssen
es gibt ein Phänomen was psychologisch
unglaublich interessant ist und
gleichzeitig wie oft bei psychologischen
Phänomen gerade ganz ganz viele Menschen
belastet die Klima Angst Klima Angst das
klingt schon fast wie eine psychische
Störung wie eine Diagnose und das ist es
auf keinen Fall Angst vor realen
Gefahren ist gut auch wenn sich die
Angst nicht gut anfühlt brauchen wir
Angst weil wir sonst nicht handeln weil
wir sonst nichts verändern wie viel
Angst wie viel Klima Angst habt ihr die
haben wir natürlich ganz große
Kinder
alleine
ja du hast mehr Klemme Angst als der
Vater einfach weil das wenn das jetzt so
weitergeht wie die Bundesregierung
beschlossen hat Kernkraftwerke
abzustellen dann befürchte ich einfach
dass wir an den fossilen hängen bleiben
und immer weiter die CO2 imitieren wir
sollten mehr Angst vor dem Klimawandel
haben als vor der Atomkraft weil die ist
100% Erneuerbare entschuldige
daran glaube ich nicht ich weiß dass ich
unter den Leuten die die Klimakrise
erleben jetzt schon zu dem
privilegierteren gehören ich weiß dass
ich in Deutschland verhältnismäßig
sicher bin ich weiß dass wir uns
verhältnismäßig gut schützen können was
auch das viele andere Leute viel stärker
Folgen erleben werden habe ich
verstanden
[Musik]
wir haben noch kein Atome entlager
gerade wird in der Schweiz diskutiert ob
man nicht direkt an die Grenze zu
Baden-Württemberg 1 baut es wird also
konkret mit dem Atommüll Endlager wo zum
Teil Stoffe drin lagern die über 1
Million Jahre strahlen und auch noch
viel länger wie viel Angst hättest du
vor einem Atommüll Endlager vor deiner
Haustür
kann ich Dir auch gerne helfen ja alles
gut ich setze mich mal hinten symbolisch
drauf weil ich muss jetzt nicht die
ganze Zeit stehen mitten in
Niedersachsen klatschen wir jetzt ein
Atommüll Endlager hin wie nah wird es so
an dein Haus ranlassen sagen wir mal 5
km von deinem Haus entfernt maximale
Angst
also meine große Angst ist eigentlich
wenn wir irgendwie ein Endlager finden
wollen und wir arbeiten schon seit 30 40
Jahren da dran ein Endlager zu finden
dann wird das mein Leben lang mir als
zukünftigen Steuerzahler auf der Tasche
liegen Atom Endlager vor eurer Haustür
wohnt auf dem Land schöne tolle
Landschaft da kommen die Bagger an
sofort ich möchte Verantwortung
übernehmen natürlich auch wir alle also
du würdest auch nehmen Endlager ziehen
natürlich weil ich denke ja ich möchte
Verantwortung übernehmen auch für
unseren Müll da ist jetzt wieder ganz
klar der Generation Konflikt sehr sehr
spannend wir hatten ja schon mal eine
Folge über das Klima die ich unbedingt
empfehlen möchte falls Sie noch nicht
gesehen habt mit Jan Fleischer und kalor
wo wir auch immer wieder diesen
Generationen Punkt hatten das ist ja
einfach Fakt ich sage das so leicht
daher aber natürlich sterben unsere
Eltern früher als wir im Schnitt ist das
für dich ein Punkt dass du sagst ich bin
früher von diesem Planeten Weg deswegen
ist mir das egal
das schmerzt
schmerzt und ich glaube einfach dass wir
die Kontrolle behalten können über den
Atommüll wenn wir über das CO2 einfach
die Kontrolle gerade verlieren hast du
da nicht Respekt vor dass dann jemand
sagt ich betrachte das so ganzheitlich
und wird auch wirklich neben dieses
Endlager ziehen ist auf jeden Fall
konsequent das würde ich schon sagen
kommt noch mal runter von den Leitern
zurück auf die Couch
[Musik]
die beiden Ängste mal greifbar machen
denen nachgehen es ist ein angsthema
mich interessiert bei Fridays for future
dass er dieses 1,5 Grad Ziel ganz
konkreter steht und aktuell sieht es
eigentlich unglaublich düster aus man
hat das Gefühl wenn es so weitergeht wie
bisher packen wir das nicht CO2 muss
radikal ganz schnell runter es ist in
deinem Kopf so dass du dann Ängste
gegeneinander abwägst dass du sagst die
Angst vor der Klimakatastrophe versus
Reaktorunfall nee weil dieses Bild der
Waage
impliziert ja einen entweder oder ja
aber so funktioniert Energiepolitik
einfach nicht beschreib mal Ulrike als
wir gerade auf den Leitern rauf und
runtergegangen sind wo hast du dich mit
Linus verbunden gefühlt wo hast du
gedacht oh guck mal ja
Ablehnung der Braunkohle nicht dass das
als in der dass das als Backup jetzt im
Moment auch noch gerade priorisiert wird
fast vor der Kernkraft ich glaube da
waren wir uns ziemlich einig und und
überhaupt die Sorge um den Klimawandel
waren wir uns einig waren ja schon viele
Punkte wo wir eigentlich ist eigentlich
im Grunde nur dieser Weg das ist
eigentlich im Grunde nur diese Idee geht
100%. ja oder nein ich glaube wir waren
uns ja eigentlich immer bei einer Sache
einig beim Ziel beim Ziel und bei der
Angst also wir haben dieselbe Problem
Analyse im Kern und das ist wir haben
die Klimakrise die wird von fossilen
Technologien verursacht
was ich so interessant finde ist aber
dass man so engagiert gegen die
Klimakrise sein kann und dann eine
andere Technologie befürwortet die im
Kern doch relativ ähnlich funktioniert
wir werden das nicht schaffen so viel
Wind und so an sonnenparks hinzustellen
dass wir am Ende eine große Nation wie
Deutschland ist sicher mit günstigen
Strom zuverlässig versorgen können es
ist ein Thema was von unglaublich vielen
Fakten lebt die haben wir heute auch an
vielen Stellen schon gehabt und trotzdem
ist es ja auch eins wo es um Zukunft
geht wo sich ganz viel nicht genau sagen
Liste da will ich jetzt noch mal voll
emotional mit euch rein wenn ihr noch
mal kurz helfen ein bisschen Platz zu
schaffen können wir das gut machen
ich möchte jetzt mit euch ganz konkret
die größte Angst die ihr zum Thema
Atomkraft in Deutschland die größte
Angst die ihr dazu habt dass wir die mal
zu Ende denken Linus beschreib mal dass
aus deiner Sicht krasseste was passieren
könnte was die am allermeisten Angst
machen würde also das alle was einem am
allermeisten Angst macht ist für mich
immer der Super-GAU auf einer Skala von
1 bis 10 wie hoch wäre diese Angst wenn
es passiert zehn also sehr schön wir
machen hier keine echte Therapie das
hoffentlich klar deswegen darfst du
jetzt auch die Rolle einer Therapeutin
einnehmen und gleich versuchen indem du
Linus immer wieder fragst was wird dann
passiert was passiert als nächstes wie
fühlt sich das für dich an mit dir
dieses Band voll auf Spannung zu bringen
es gab einen ein Schaden in der
Kühlsystem
wir steigen direkt das Atomkraftwerk
explodiert
fühlst du was geht hier durch den Kopf
überhaupt nicht wissen was ich tue und
ich glaube die meisten um mich auch
nicht weil das nicht normalerweise
passiert und entsprechend für die Angst
schon sofort sehr nah sehr plötzlich
relativ hoch würdest du weglaufen ich
glaube wenn ich neben dem Atomkraftwerk
wäre auf jeden Fall wollte ich gerade
sagen das Atomkraftwerk steht in
Deutschland in der Nähe von Göttingen wo
du wohnst und jetzt weiter rein in die
Angst was passiert als nächstes ist
jemand umgekommen von deiner Familie
vielleicht direkt ja also wenn das
passieren würde dann wäre die Angst
natürlich sofort viel höher aber man
merkt und man sieht die Effekte und man
weiß auch eben dass es jetzt schon so
viel kostet für einen auch persön
Gott ich weiß nicht sagen wir mal alle
sind tot und die Angst davor ist maximal
also ich glaube dass man direkt von so
etwas betroffen sein kann
das ist unvorstellbar und du hast gerade
überlebt und vielleicht
erkrankt oder irgendwie hast du das
Gefühl da genau also jetzt nicht nur
Angst um meine Familie auch um mich sie
Angst natürlich gibt es drauf du
schaffst das Formulieren absolut also
unvorstellbar ich weiß nicht mal mehr ob
man
die Angst die man vor Sonnen hätte die
ich versuche uns nach Johann habe wenn
es passiert dann
unbeschreiblich bei der Übung mit dem
Band konnte man schon sehr spüren dass
ihm das sehr nahe gegangen ist und man
spürt auch einfach wie wie tief das in
ihm drin steckt und jetzt auch Angst
dass unsere ganze Kultursystem die
Schulen alles inkludiert Menschen in
Chaos ja weil weil es unruhbar ist und
ich weiß auch dass die Orte die mir
etwas bedeuten dass die verloren
gegangen sind und auch eben die
Gemeinschaften die Gemeinden die mir
etwas bedeuten dass die auch verloren
gegangen sind und das ist für mich total
total das ist unvorstellbar du meinst
wir könnten es nicht mehr davon
eigentlich erholen es würde einfach
Deutschland für die nächsten hunderte
von Jahren
wenn das in meiner Stadt wäre dann würde
es meine Stadt zerstören dann würde
meine Stadt nie wieder sein wie vorher
jetzt richtig maximal Deutschland ganz
Europa wäre
ich glaube das könnte passieren ich
glaube es wäre eben kein könnte wir
haben jetzt diese Situation das
Atomkraftwerkes nehmen Göttingen
explodiert du sitzt da deine Mutter ist
tot dein Vater ist tot deine Freundin
ist tot deine nächsten anderen
Angehörigen sind tot da ist überall
Schuld und Asche du merkst langsam der
Krebs nackt an dir dir geht's richtig
schlecht du sitzt komplett zerstört in
der Ecke dieses Gefühl ist das was wir
jetzt haben wollen kommt das in dir auf
ja es kommt immer auf ich glaube es ist
mir noch nie in der Form in mir
aufgekommen vorher
aber ich glaube wenn man diese Angst mal
empfindet dann kann man das nicht
einfach so stehen lassen dann kann man
nicht sagen ach ist eine sichere
Technologie bevor wir diese bevor wir
diese Situation hatten bevor ich ihm das
vorstellen musste hatte ich nie wirklich
viel Angst tatsächlich von einem
Super-GAU ich wusste immer das ist ja
unwahrscheinlich ist aber diese
Vorstellung mal ausgelebt zu haben hat
es für mich auf jeden Fall noch mal
deutlich eindrücklicher gemacht jetzt
dein Job sie maximal hochzutreiben du
hast gesagt das wäre deine krasse
Blackout in Deutschland nicht genug
Strom die ersten Krankenhäuser fallen
aus katastrophale Zustände los geht's
und voll rein in die Angst sagen wir es
ist Winter und du fängst an das zu
spüren dass dich eben der Strom ihr habt
eine Stromheizung dass dich der Strom
nicht mehr erreicht ja es ist eine Angst
das ist eine ganz große Angst ja dass
eben auch gleich alles ausfällt es fehlt
sofort es gibt kein Klo mehr es gibt
keinen es wird alles dunkel der
Kühlschrank funktioniert nicht mehr kann
nichts mehr aufbewahren Essen wird
schlecht ein Essen
soziale Aufstände und
ja also das ist schon eine große Angst
okay dann sagen wir mal wirklich alles
also das gesamte Stromnetz funktioniert
nicht mehr es ist
überhaupt nicht mehr möglich auch sagen
wir mal zum Arzt zu gehen du kannst
nicht ins Krankenhaus vielleicht hat
jemand eine Verletzung und ihr könnt ihn
nicht behandeln lassen es gibt kein OP
mehr davon funktioniert ganz furchtbarer
Angst weil natürlich auf den auf den
Intensivstationen der Strom nicht mehr
funktioniert Intensivpatienten nicht
mehr beatmet werden können Panik dass
man in irgendwo mehr hin kann man kann
das Auto nicht mehr tanken man kann
nirgendwohin die er mein Mann liegt im
Krankenhaus alleine und im Krankenhaus
ist Chaos weil jeder nur noch für sich
selber sucht und für sich selber sorgt
das würde mir wahnsinnig Angst machen
weil in so einer Situation Menschen nur
noch an sich selbst denken und die
Mensch der Mensch der Mensch zum Tier
wird ne also sagen wir mal mehr
Familienangehöriger oder du musst dich
um deinen Mann kümmern du musst
versuchen ihn irgendwie in der Region
mit Strom zu bringen und dann weißt du
nicht was mit deinen Kindern passiert
oder du kannst deine Kinder nicht
erreichen einfach völlige Verzweiflung
und natürlich ja umso mehr verzweifelt
noch weil ich gewusst hätte wir hätten
wir vielleicht einen anderen Weg
eingeschlagen dann dann wäre vielleicht
nicht zu diesen katastrophalen Zuständen
gekommen wir hätten ja wir hätten uns
vielleicht da hätte funktionieren können
und jetzt ist es alles vorbei maximal in
die Angst gegangen maximal zog hier auf
diesem Band vielen Dank Ulrike wir
hatten glaube ich im letzten Winter
hatten wir sechs Wochen lang gar keine
Sonne es war ja ein ganz furchtbar
dunkler Winter dann können wir alle nur
zu Hause sitzen und beten das ist
irgendwie wieder was kommt ja weil sonst
muss man im Krankenhaus sagen ihr müsst
jetzt irgendwie weiß nicht kürzer
weniger Strom abnehmen einzelne Städte
abstellen und
ich habe sehr viel besser verstanden was
ihre Ängste sind und wieso sie so
motiviert ist für Atomkraft einzutreten
beide durchatmen ja und weiter geht's
Angst auf die Spitze treiben ist was was
grundsätzlich sehr unangenehm ist aber
eben weil die Sorgen oft im Hinterkopf
uns eher dann blockieren und nicht zum
Handeln bringen ist dieses in die Angst
gehen etwas was total viel mit einem
macht und was vor allem Handlungsimpulse
aus ist also jetzt was tun einfach
natürlich dafür sorgen dass wir die drei
Kernkraftwerke die noch gerade laufen
und die drei die wir kürzlich
abgeschaltet haben letztes Jahr einfach
wieder ins Netz bringen und mit zu
stabilisieren helfen und für dich was
ist der Handlung ist Impuls aus dieser
Übung
alle
Ressourcen die wir haben in erneuerbare
Energien stecken sich gar nicht mehr mit
Atomkraft beschäftigen sonst da lassen
wo es faktisch ist und zwar in der
Vergangenheit jetzt mal Hoffnung wir
drehen den Spieß um was haben die beiden
vielleicht auch an gemeinsam Wünschen
für die Zukunft
[Musik]
so viel Unterschiede so viel Konflikt
und trotzdem muss ich am Ende zusammen
funktionieren und da würde ich jetzt
vorschlagen dass ihr bitte beide einmal
zusammen auf diesen sehr kleinen Teppich
steigt
kriegen wir das hin zwischendurch hatte
ich das Gefühl ihr wart kurz davor aber
wir wissen auch ihr seid eigentlich
total weit voneinander getrennt können
wir mit einer Umarmung starten so bleibt
kurz zusammen wir stehen jetzt auf
diesem Teppich wir beiden jetzt in
diesem in diesem Moment ganz konkret die
Zukunft der Atomkraft in Deutschland
dass ihr da Kritik aneinander habt dass
ihr überhaupt nicht einig seid ist klar
geworden versucht mal Sachen zu sagen
die diese Umarmung auch noch zulässt wir
wollen die Klimakrise stoppen wir wollen
die Kinder stoppen dass das Ziel
Erneuerbaren ausbauen oha eindeutig wir
wollen beide sichere Energie wir wollen
beide dass wir immer Energie haben und
wir wollen dass die Energie dabei keine
Menschen tötet genau wir wollen Energie
auch zur sozialen Preisen haben dass sie
sich jeder leisten kann ja viel wenn man
so darüber nachdenkt aber eine Sache
halt nicht Atomkraft die eine will sie
unbedingt andere auf keinen Fall halten
ihr bleibt zusammen zum Punkt Atomkraft
ich kann dir vielleicht sagen liebe
Linus vielleicht so lang wir diese und
natürlich wenigstens lang wenn diese
Krise jetzt haben was in Russland ist
diese Gaskrise und allem dass wir doch
alle sechs Atomkraftwerke wieder an den
Start bringen einfach um ein Super-GAU
den der vielleicht sogar kommen könnte
verhindern zu helfen Linus
die Umarmung zu halten da sage ich
leider schon nee mein Vorschlag ist wir
stecken all die Milliarden Euro die in
die bisher in Subventionen geflossen
sind die in weitere Endlager fließen
müssten die stecken wirklich ganz tief
versprochen alle in die Forschung für
große Batterieanlagen und für Linus was
glaubst du das hält die Umarmung stand
und ich glaube das ist auch okay ihr
steht zumindest noch auf dieser Fußmatte
zusammen Therapiesitzung 1
wahrscheinlich bräuchten wir noch viele
und ihr würdet am Ende trotzdem sagen
wir bleiben bei unterschiedlichen
Standpunkten dieses Thema ist riesig
dieses Thema ist komplex vielen vielen
Dank dass ihr beide hier bei unserer
Paartherapie der Meinung mal eure
Meinung geteilt haben alles Gute euch
beiden vielen Dank
die nimmt meine Position ernst auch wenn
sie mir nicht zustimmt und ich habe auch
ihre Position ernst genommen auch wenn
ich die für komplett falsch halte und
das ist eigentlich ganz gut dass man
egal woher man kommt auf einer Ebene
diese Debatte führen kann weil sie muss
geführt werden ich glaube das war ein
guter Austausch und es hat auch wirklich
einfach noch mal ähm festgestellt das
sind wirklich nur diese Argumente die
uns auseinander bringen am Ende wird die
Meinung von uns allen sein in dieser
Demokratie ob es wieder Atomkraft ob es
mehr Atomkraft vielleicht sogar gibt
oder nicht und die beiden haben eine
krasse Meinung und wenn du glaubst dass
wir darüber diskutieren müssen dass wir
uns eine Meinung will sollten dann Teil
doch dieses Video
[Musik]